[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
do you like ghost stories
oh my goodness a show so nice we started
it twice welcome back to the break room
hit my graphic
that's right this is our daily news show
that keeps you updated on what's going
on in nerd news they heard me choking on
the gym thank goodness right here live
they couldn't hear anything else they
just heard you
joking on a chair that's good we're live
right here from our very own break group
we're having a couple of snacks before
the show started hey at any time during
the show you notice jessica joking
please
throw a choking emoji in the chat what's
the choker
how do you kids signal to your your
partner i think you want to be true
keep an eye on jessica throughout the
show we want to make sure she doesn't
enjoy i choke on my food
i get too excited
folks we got a packed show today we got
so much to talk about we're going to
talk about guardians of the galaxy
casting news uh some kenobi updates uh
and lady gaga so you know this is gonna
be a good show yeah that's her name
that's her christian name lady gaga
lady gaga
we're all goo for
uh
god
me on
the esteemed panel today we've got
whitney van landing and say hello
everyone hello hi
i'm here
congratulations and next to her we also
have jessica glenn yeah
someone who always passes the gas it's
tommy bechtol
hello everyone it's a medical condition
and i don't want to talk about it
however
you can join my discord thomas medical
tommy's medical traumas where i'll
update you every day on my various
appointments and transfusions that's
right a lot of medical ailments here on
the uh the break room so watch out for
all of us if any of our power fades
during the show please just let us throw
a ghost emoji in the chat except for
that one person that contacted me on
twitter once and was like i think you're
having a cardiovascular event that was a
month ago so guess what it's still going
on baby not guilty
hey
we've got a chat redemption going on
today and you may have heard of it it's
called the swear jar what's the swear
jar first person ever see the show asks
well if we get enough super chats to
equal one hundred dollars
we'll squeak out a little curse for you
okay and we're gonna let the chat
actually vote on who gets to swear today
when the votes are back baby the votes
are back uh so send in those super chats
if you got questions you got statements
if you notice jessica's choking send in
a super chat let us know
those things back again
i'm gonna choke
tell
my mom
call my emergency contact yeah
tell me make sure you have ice contacts
we can't call you in case of emergency
we can't tell your mom she's too busy
scouring espn figuring out if the
seahawks are going to trade for a
quarterback okay you guys turn off this
camera because i'm all done
uh while we wait for jessica to uh
physically assault tommy let's get into
some headlines
that's right headlines the news you need
to know
deadline is reporting that superstore
and crazy rich age asians star nico
santos has been cast in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. who do you all want him to
play and do we think he's gonna play i
want him to play his character and crazy
rich asians
that character is not only very funny uh
very smart and a style icon so i want to
see that in space
isn't it interesting that guardians of
the galaxy 3 is like that new it's like
the
it's the more diverse version of the
manhattan project casting where like one
by one every day
every our
every actor
in hollywood was getting cast in it but
they were all white men this is like all
of your favorite character actors are
gonna show up in this movie in guardians
of the galaxy 3. which is rap filming as
far as we know a month and a half ago
but they're like
they were very good about these secret
cameos because we didn't know about the
girl from borat yeah yeah i don't know
who he should play
uh there's so many weird cosmic
characters you can be i feel like uh
james gunn loves to have these kind of
just like
cameos and weird little one-off
characters and with the guardians it's
like we have so many main characters to
stick to plus we know we're getting a
little out of warlock in this one so i
don't know how much more he's like the
designer for adam warlock
he could be a sovereign software yeah
he'd make a great sovereign i like him
as a software yeah okay
i hope he's a software if he's not i'll
i won't go see the movie sorry i just
realized
call me off guard a little bit
rodrigo vargas sending in a super chat
force choke me jessica i got you camera
it's only two bucks i don't know
uh another headline in an interview with
fandango taika watiti said that gore the
godbutcher is the most sympathetic
villain he's had and also revealed that
gore is the highest testing marvel
villain ever
high testing higher than thanos we asked
i don't know everyone loved thanos this
is like when they show a movie ahead of
time to make sure
someone's gonna like it
yeah yeah and i guess they thought those
little comment cards and everyone's
saying oh we love doors but this is also
taikawati they
in his interview was also like uh when i
was supposed to play blackbeard i looked
him up noticed that that i couldn't do
that voice i did my own voice i'm very
lazy and i'm successful so what about it
and that's what i love about him and i
think in this interview he's like this
is my movie this is the best super
villain that's his best villain ever
yeah
mine's the best he's like i nailed it i
killed it it's going to be awesome i
mean i feel like
the marvel movies have really trended
towards these like sympathetic villains
because there's a lot of way i felt for
wen will right i was kind of on
wednesday yeah yeah he misses his wife
he thinks he hears her
calling out from the other side he's a
little crazy he's been alive for a
thousand years that's true he's gonna
pass and wouldn't you do anything to get
your love back who you think is trapped
in like a dimension of darkness wouldn't
you fight anything i mean it depends you
know
what where are we in the relationship is
it five years five years five years
do we live together by then you're
living together there's no long-term
commitment you've earned a five-year
relationship you're living together
what's your job
their job uh they make more money than
you okay
that's for sure that's right folks marry
up whenever you can
it's a great move uh another headline uh
rupert friend went on jimmy kimmel last
friday and jimmy did his best to get him
to admit his character was going to come
back in kenobi uh when jimmy kimmel
mentioned the grand inquisitor getting
stabbed in the stomach friend corrected
him by saying
one of his stomachs
i don't know how many stomachs a grand
inquisitor has a cow has four two so
four non-inquisitors oh how's that four
yeah yeah but he referred in the
interview he says he's a half a cow he's
half down
he's got that then he's got two i get
all my cappuccinos half pasta
yeah yeah i get all my cappuccinos but
the milk has to come from one of the
stomachs not the otters
that's good i only get duncanchinos oh
don't get
about a remote control uh but he's
definitely coming back right no 100
i still think it could be a clone or
like a different one
i mean i do like the idea that vader
is a step ahead of riva and is like
making her think that he's dead and it's
like he's been alive the whole time
could they keep like an unlimited clone
of the grand inquisitor always comes
just to always have one yeah yeah
did they have anything like that in the
game
not that i know of not that i know of
dots and if that's in the game let us
know uh but i do know that like the
emperor put together the whole
inquisitor's sect right and then kind of
gave him to vayner as like a job oh yeah
here you hate these guys i'm going to
make you be in charge of you so it would
be a funny trick of the emperor just be
like man i have hundreds of grand
inquisitors
yeah i think
silence i think that like the truth like
riva has got to have just be ultimately
betrayed by the end of this but oh i
mean definitely she's already clearly
feels betrayed by kenobi for something
that they've revealed yet i'm sure
that's probably coming in this episode
or maybe the finale but it's like yeah
in the end with vader just being like
this whole time i was telling you you'd
be in charge but it's actually this guy
and then she can just be like i have
nobody i have nothing yeah now i gotta
just get out there and start killing
people
i mean they have kind of played vader as
like the
the manager who has no idea what's going
on uh and i think some people have
complained that like what's up with
vader he's like not seeing through these
ruses that riva's throwing up i think
he's like way ahead of her yeah
would i rather be feared or loved yeah
i'd rather have people be afraid of how
much they love me yeah perfect um uh
episode five coming out tonight of the
obi-wan kenobi series at midnight also
ms marvel so much to watch uh this
evening stay up late don't do what your
parents say and go to bed
who cares if you're bossing up late
tonight
whitney you have to kill your family by
midnight
by midnight you don't have time to stay
up watching these shows because you've
got murderers
way too much
the paid's great though the pay is great
i don't want to talk about killing
families but i do want to talk about
costa rica qualifying for the fifa world
cup our boy sergio gutierrez just
donated to the super chat and he should
be celebrating that world cup birth but
instead oh he's watching with us and i
gotta say sergio you're a real one for
that yeah
can't wait for the world cup definitely
being held in a great place with no
problems whatsoever uh listen folks
netflix is releasing a reality show
version of its mega hit squid game uh so
they're gonna do like a real life
version of the squiggly oh that's just
netflix is just killing people now i
mean they don't have the guts
already did that yeah
we'll get into that in a second i think
what netflix is going to do is going to
take all the people sharing passwords
and force them to be on the show
you shouldn't write your terms of
service when you signed up for netflix
don't show that password i mean for my
netflix when i watch one show and it's
not coming back on until july then
you're gonna wake up in a room full of
bunk beds courtesy of netflix
this show is gonna feature 456
contestants competing for a prize of
4.56
million dollars uh netflix is saying
this is the largest lump sum cash prize
ever given out on a reality tv program
to one person i guess that's true
yeah the show it only went to one person
right it only goes to one person right
right like what are the taxes gonna be
on that because obviously whenever you
win money on like any reality show like
who wants to really be a millionaire
because tommy does not do his taxes i
don't pay taxes yeah he can't you don't
know who i really am i have no
fingerprints yeah that's why they call
him tommy tax-free
if you're in the chat right now and you
work for the irs get out of there yeah
we don't want you on the show yeah get
out you work for the irs please just
like make it so that none of us have to
pay yeah be nice there's some poor guy
there he's out here he's obsessed with
this show that works for the irs and
he's like my one joy after a day of
making people financially miserable is
coming home and watching the break room
and you just told me to stop watching no
i take it back please watch the break
the breakthrough oh no
no
everyone everyone pay your taxes do your
civic duty it's the best thing we could
do what have they done for me okay keep
going
guys just remember
three years ago we all got 1200 so if
you're having financial trouble that's
your own fault pull yourself up by your
bootstraps we're all doing good
subscribe to netflix stop eating avocado
it's true
uh lady gaga in a is an early talks to
star opposite joaquin phoenix and
director todd phillips sequel to
joker wow uh the oscar-winning one
billion dollar grossing 2019 warner
brothers hit based on the dc villain
that we all remember so fondly oh my god
the craziest thing about this story is
my phone is going on yeah no the
craziest thing about this story is that
apparently this joker sequel is going to
be a musical yes
the guy lady good guy she's gonna sing
shallow i don't know what she's gonna
sing in it can i can i make a can i make
a pitch please make a pitch this is a
different universe where this joker is
alive or is existing in what's stopping
us from casting bradley cooper as batman
in this nothing he can sing i'm batman
i'm an eccentric billionaire
my parents are dead
but look at my hair
when i'm bruce wayne i act all kooky
yeah
but when i'm batman i act all spooky
yeah
that's a great song those in the chat
saying no musical
you didn't like that you didn't like
that that was hot i mean i assume all
the we talked about this the a lot of
the musical stuff will be
probably in the fantasy realm like
imagine like the film chicago if you're
familiar with that movie musical won the
oscars i don't watch musicals oh you
should they're great they're great oh
they're beautiful they're great
but yeah this is kind of a crazy story
and i'm fascinated that they're gonna do
another version of harley considering i
think harley's their most popular
property in the dc universe maybe i was
doing everyone loves martial i was like
harley quinn i don't need it because i
have enough marvel and i have enough
joker but this is top phillips joker so
i was like i'm okay with joker i've had
enough harley and trust me you guys i
love harley she's my next tattoo but
when they said musical and they said
lady gaga i said oh come on i've got
[Applause]
right over the mountain right over the
mountain
here we go i would personally really
appreciate seeing harley quinn in a meat
dress
i think that that's what we should add i
mean that's nice
especially with her hyena pals right
yeah
a couple polls we've been running in the
chat when we see the grand inquisitor
return most of you 62 saying the season
finale saving it for the very end i
think that makes a lot of sense uh
another poll was would you compete in a
real life squid game 75 percent said no
understandable i don't want to die right
but i need this netflix version no one's
done no one's dying we're not talking
about that you're saying real real i
don't know that no one's gonna die i
mean that's true
show they take your pants yeah they take
care of it that's why i'd never
participated i would probably
participate and i would try my hardest
to lose because i need them to take my
cat away oh my god
i love her if she's watching this at
home cat how are you watching this turn
up you don't pay the bills
get down from my computer turn off the
old youtube this is not gonna be a
burrito episode with that killing your
cat joke
also in the chat uh we read a poem do
you think lady gaga will be a better
harley quinn than margot robbie 72
saying no
uh
so i think margot robbie marco she's
great she's as great as harley quinn
okay
me and someone got an argument about
this because they were like well why
don't you just train
like margot robbie to sing and i'm like
that's not how this works that is not
how this works and also don't overlap
margot robbie's voice with someone else
singing because that is also problematic
and so i'm like it just sucks that we as
like established margot robbie as the
harley quinn then now we're like also
lady gaga but i hope they can
differentiate the two by making this one
the musical one different and this one's
just our canon one where the musical
variation is harley quinn where she's
from the universe where everyone just
sings and it's lady gaga lady gaga
where was this fervent defense of jared
leto yeah thank you thank you why didn't
we stand up for jared leto i mean he was
in uh what was his band called 30
seconds
seconds he was a great musician
one of the greatest of our time
he's a great cult leader so we're also
talking about what was found on the
marvel website you want me again that's
right well do you want to get it i'm
getting into it
this is the most insane thing that's
ever happened to at least me today
i have a very reckless wild lifestyle so
this doesn't top it but it's close the
official marvel website has confirmed
that a shield agent observed avengers
end games final battle and published a
book called i was there about the event
which featured at miss marvel's avengers
con there's a photo right there it's
kind of weird because you had to zoom in
on it and
this is insane the fact that they were
like hey this guy uh saw the entire
battle wrote a book about it but was six
thousand feet away yeah and there's also
a million other things that were there
yeah this was a post on marvel's website
this is an official from them
uh
i hope kevin feige looked at it before i
got posted
you guys this exists it was put up i
smell a hoax he smells you cannot smell
a hoax here you cannot
this cannot be tinfoil hat tommy
this guy i think this is like when when
that broadcaster brian williams was like
i was flying all those combat missions
yeah exactly i think it's to be they're
going to find out that this dude do you
think this shield aj yeah yeah i was
going to say that it's going to be like
gilderoy lockhart and harry potter yeah
somebody else was there but they
probably died and he found out somehow
and stole it from that yeah
he wasn't there this is insane that it
definitely flew over kevin feige's head
he was like oh an article on my website
whatever and then literally this just
ripples so much things and conflicts
with so much other things that they're
gonna have to either
wipe it or go through like going forward
like the next ant-man wasp will have
like we're gonna talk about like for
instance in the
the avengers con ant-man is referred to
as only gigantic dude
and he has a podcast we know him as
ant-man so why does everyone only know
him as gigantic dude well i think maybe
that's how they're referring to him at
that khan because they also have the
ants that when they yeah
but not one thing said ant-man it was
like get your gigantic dude punch here's
his gigantic dude podcast here's his job
and i was like are you guys is it
illegal to say
maybe he is marketing himself as
gigantic dude yeah
maybe he doesn't want to be noticed it's
more fun
anymore yeah he's like i want to be a
gigantic i want to be a big old guy a
big old dude big old dick
tell me about it
so hulk's part of the vendors con you
can go to the hulk rage room which
genuinely is a good idea that is a great
idea someone should be marketing
immediately
let's do that here let's build a whole
great room at one of the empty offices
that's actually a great actually you
know you can head back on our channel go
back in time a little bit and check out
last year's fitness origins
both eric voss and i doing a hulk rage
room uh in sumo suits i almost had a
panic attack inside the sumo
it was legitimately one of the more
miserable moments of my life so check
out that video to see me in real life
melting down jesus okay also
i'm sorry i'm so sorry no no
in the whole portion of avengers con
they also have smashed items from the
hulk the new york city cab some cinder
blocks because who doesn't want a cinder
block a shopping cart a fridge and hulk
merch
i think a little bit of this though i
smell a hoax you smell yeah i think this
is like how uh uh all these like uh
catholic churches have like relics from
the saints or whatever it's like you
could just take a fridge and hit it with
a sledgehammer exactly like hulk smashed
this me and my brother used to smash
cabs all the time yeah in the backyard
and sell them as hulk caps
that was all we paid for college the
hulk merch also said like it was
something that said like um
you don't want to see me angry but you
won't see me angry at avenger con and
that's why i keep thinking that this is
owned by someone higher up that's just
making money someone that's about money
like wilson fisk money so that's why it
does feel like a griff
there's the captain marvel section at um
avengers con where you can get her book
carol a definitive account of the cosmic
avenger a book aimed to unfold the true
identity of captain marvel which i
forgot no one knows that she's carol
danvers
but i guess it's like i guess if they
haven't released that information
because
then why is the book called carol
yeah well i guess they would know her
name's carol danvers but they don't know
who carol danvers
could look her up because she would have
military records unless they've scrubbed
all that i don't know oh they might have
scrubbed it
these are the conflicts that i need
someone to address in the future of the
mcu captain america not only do they
have artwork honoring his butt
which is insane when i die i want
someone to just make a bunch of artwork
honoring my butt i want people honoring
captain america but i want my gravestone
to be his cheeks yeah let's do it let's
let's go in does anybody in here make
tombstones did you go to jessica's grave
today i did i planted flowers and i
clapped captain america
and i clapped that ass clap god i miss
her
you can do um there's merch the all i
can do this all day from is play for the
guardians of the galaxy you get the 40
minute documentary series pay to all
planets the peter quill starboy story
rocket has a trash panda alley which is
a slightly offensive um where you can
scavenge for a good prize and group
because they don't know groot's name is
groot yeah just call mr trees house for
your botanical needs yeah they have like
a tree house that was the most
fascinating to one to me they say this
in this article on the website that's
like no one knows that his name was
groot like the civilians don't know his
name is groot which if all this other
information got out how did his name not
get well it's because no one can speak
his language except for free but they
all hear i am groot
it would like really blow civilians
minds if they knew that vin diesel was
also i mean that would it would blow
that right blow their minds no wait
that's big diesel that's also been
diesel mr trees vin diesel he just comes
in wait a minute mr tree and dominic
toretto are the same guys yeah that's
the whole world we read a poll in the
chat is this a fake book this like
shield account of the endgame battle uh
and sixty percent of you said yes yes i
think it is
this is like when you go to like a mufon
right like the ufo conventions and
there's like all these books about like
i saw this or i talked to the cia guy or
blah blah blah it's all just made up and
people running a griff my favorite part
about this is who did the book though
who was the guy that wrote the book is
it gonna be actually a former shield
agent that's like i don't have a job now
or this and i wasn't one of the racist
like is it what is he gonna what's it i
feel like it has to like it i can't wait
to see it be like kumail in kenobi where
it's like i'm a fake
so i want to know who it is because also
they said in the book that they have
some uh accounts from hawkeye who talks
to hawkeye yeah who talked to hawkeye he
was like an outcast he's an outcast
he's at a farm in the middle of nowhere
he doesn't talk to anyone but his family
lauren's pug is mad yeah i mean in
theory they could have run into him
while he was running somewhere and
they're like can i have a few moments of
your time but they no one knew hot guy
was wrong
a few moments of your time please i
don't speak to the press
oh the only
way i was giving them was that maybe it
was hawkeye's wife that wrote it because
she did work for shield right briefly
yeah i mean this battle this battle
why would you do it
yeah oh maybe they need the money they
got a lot of kids
this battle happens in upstate new york
right in the kind of isolated avengers
facility but it makes sense that like
someone saw it someone nearby must have
seen it or you'd have been like what's
all that noise over there or i'm gonna
go see what what that's all about uh i
think we were most blown away though
that this article says of a shield agent
even though at this point shield's been
gone for
uh four or five years like post-winner
soldier shields kind of dissolve
now agents we were talking about agents
of shield a little bit uh eric vos had a
theory that this is one of those uh
marvel insiders who loves agents of
shield and is trying to get it canonized
as much as they can agents of shield was
still going on post-winner soldier but
they were kind of operating in the
shadows they were like a smaller
contingent
and we also know
or we think agents of shield is in like
a branch timeline at some point it
branches off from the main one because
they haven't really brought coulson back
in the main mcu
uh and then at the end of agents of seal
we see that the triskel triskelion is
still there so some things went
different in the agents of shield world
i mean i think the dark hole is
different of course
because the ghost of coulson could have
totally overseen the whole battle he
said i'm writing a book
you gotta possess somebody to write yeah
i know that shield is dead but nothing
is really actually dead and also if you
had shield if your title was something
of shield and you are now nothing
because the thing that she left behind
it
do you think it's too hard to believe
that there actually is a shield agent
that did write the book
i it's not out of the realm of
possibility and certainly if this agent
has no job anymore it's like i'm totally
gonna write this book i'm totally
writing about now we don't know if the
book's narrative is bad or good right
because
they're like yeah what if he's like they
were monsters the superheroes are wrong
and it's actually because he's like i
lost my job
i feel like i was there is kind of an
antagonist right yeah yes
yeah if i did oh no i also like that if
he's watching from the sideline there's
a lot going on like i don't know how
he's tracking from six every three
thousand feet away yeah and maybe you
know some of these heroes but some of
you being like i don't recognize that
one and like all the wizards coming
through from con or sorcerer's coming
from commentary you'd be like oh those
ones i should know
i don't know that one i love the
specificity it's like he was 6 000 feet
away because that's how far away you
need to be to not get injured he's the
one that put the six thousand feet in
there he was they were like how far away
were you six thousand definitely about
about six hours
for sure
i did little steps and i counted it oh
my god for everyone in the comments for
avengers con you heard me you can go to
the whole parade room you can do the
rockets trash panda alley and get a
little prize
out of all the places in avengers con
where would you want to be we don't need
to even do a poll you can just shout it
out in the comments while we go over
some super chats but i want to know
because i would even though it's
offensive would do rockets panda trash
panda alley searching through trash for
like little prizes is very fun i mean
you mentioned people that they're like
real trash though yeah i think it is
it's just the trash from the gun go
ahead and go through it uh you were
talking oh it's gone now anyways
well uh you were talking about camille
uh
someone mentioned like what about king
girl because he
like mentioned knowing captain america
that would be really funny
wrote this dang and that's also like
such a character for a storyline of like
i was a superstar now i'm writing a book
right
that would be the only way for me that
they could redeem this article
right um yeah i mean this was like a
crazy article on the marvel website
check it out if you haven't they point
out a lot of little easter eggs that are
hidden throughout
yeah i didn't even go over the thor one
and the thor drinks you can get the it
was what was it though scotch and eggs
and eggs and the macaroni
it was i don't even know
it was it was ridiculous though i gotta
go back and watch this i missed all
these details
yeah there's a lot of stuff in that
event there's the little details it
looks it looks really fun is there a
channel that covers missable details it
might be i don't know i'm not 100 sure
though
i think it's uh spoilers guy yeah let us
know uh what your favorite invisible
details channel do people um chat i want
to know this from you uh going off lilo
here do you ever get be like it's canon
they know other youtubers when we talk
about like oh like a spoiler explainer
uh comics explained if we ever bring
them up for people like oh my god
pewdiepie different no i do not know him
i mean you mentioned mr beast earlier so
they know we're real yeah they know
we're not ai systems
i wouldn't be so sure the only reason i
know i'm not ai is because i got a great
night sleep
and now you know why i got a great
night's sleep last night because my
friends at helix
and we want to thank them for sponsoring
us today
as i said i got a great night's sleep
because i own a helix mattress it allows
me to sleep so soundly so that when i
wake up the first thing in the morning i
can think is what kind of mandatory fun
are we going to have and then i go to my
computer and realize i have a doctor's
appointment
i'm going to miss mandatory i have
doctor's appointments as i mentioned
yesterday i have loud
inconsiderate really quite frankly pig
men of roommates and uh my helix
mattress is a lifesaver for me because
it allows me to get a good night's sleep
despite their
incessant playing and joey i'm begging
you plug in some headphones when you're
practicing your electric guitar i know
that you think that you're the next
brian may but i think you might just be
the next
ant-may on guitar
okay as in dead as in you're gonna be
dead boy if you don't take the trash out
and put some dang headphones in
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two
one two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
as i've said i've slept on a lot of
people's mattresses before
not to brag bragging you've goldilocks
the situation that's right but with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep the way i sleep thrashing wildly
yelling out the names of my enemies
yes
everybody's unique in helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
they have medium and they have firm
mattresses i like it as soft as possible
i want the mattress to hug me like a
burrito
they're great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot i sleep flaming hot
mattresses are great for spinal
alignment that's good you don't want
that spine crooked and they prevent
morning aches and pains and night aches
and pains and quite frankly i don't know
if that claim is true but i assume if
they cure you in the morning and they
prevent them in the morning they prevent
them at night too be weird if they
specifically targeted you at night
my pains is my favorite eagles album oh
i love night paints god i used to go to
the beach and put night night paints yes
all right they even have a helix plus
mattress for us pear-shaped beauties
that like to sleep on our helix
mattresses without worrying about
shattering that sweet sweet memory foam
and as i've said helix if you're
listening
give me one of those plus mattresses
okay
my regular helix mattress is holding up
because it's made with great materials
but it's screaming for mercy
jessica needs one two actually just send
us one we'll sleep in the same way just
go to
helixsleep.com
break room take their two-minute quiz
they're gonna match you with a
customized mattress that's gonna give
you the best sleep of your life or i'll
come sleep in the bed with
that's the tommy b guarantee that's the
tommy b and here's the kicker and here's
the sticker helix is offering up to 200
off mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's two free pillows
one for the hooch one for the gooch
do whatever you want with your pillow
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com slash break room you'd
be a fool not to get a helix mattress
someone in the comments said hulk smash
mattress
that's what i do i just i do the crybaby
on it
yeah
speaking of the cry baby oh boy it's
time for mandatory fun
that's right the segment so nice that we
play the graphic just once today oh wow
that was kind of you know it was pretty
nice
that's brand new john's been working
hard you know okay i don't want to make
him do the graphic just because i say
willy-nilly god hit that graphic again
guess what it's flag day today the
united states commemorates our red white
and blue
we in the break room commemorate our
green and red with a game we like to
call
green
or red flag now oh baby yes
unfortunately
no
i cannot be here
what are you talking about i'm so sorry
laughing at us tell me what are you
talking about things that's so funny you
better curse your way i have to go oh
they're gonna run a poll we're gonna run
a poll for the curse word we have
clocked it we want to thank uh the
person who commented mandatory fun
uh i gotta go i have a doctor's
appointment i'm actually i'm getting
fitted with um ostrich ligaments in my
heels why because i want to run faster
and jump higher so i don't know if a new
ligament
i gotta go uh animal body part it's
insane to me
fortunately you guys are in good hands i
found someone that's gonna help out it's
me it's me and once it went to camera
two i knew it was me great okay so
everybody we like red flag green flag we
have a bunch of marvel cinematic
universe prompts here and like i did
last time i want you in the chat to give
me red flags if it's a red flag and
green dot emojis if it's a green flag
and for you guys to know red flag is no
it's problematic we don't like it it's a
no-go it's a no-go green good to go go
ahead and take a green and red flag
go ahead and take green red flag
oh tommy you're paying me guys sorry i'm
actually back unfortunately they were
executing a horse that
had committed a violent crime
so the doctor was executed yeah they
were they were uh they were uh they had
to do it they were
electrocuting the family of the horses
this was all ruse just to make jessica i
guess so no no i had to remember the
time i tricked him into doing rogue
theory for me true he keeps getting me
back
i oh i get to swear oh
you are in this god bless you daschle
may christ be in your heart and may god
bless you forever
[Laughter]
and now
a curse word
you [ __ ]
all right yeah thank you td jones for
pushing us over into the swamp jar with
your mandatory fun
uh and also joseph getz saying drink
swear and make man a toy fine
kevin who says two dollars for pugsley
thank you he will love that i'm gonna
give him a carrot when i get home give
him the two dollars
give him his two bucks i want to eat
money i'll just give it to him doesn't
have to eat the money
buy some crypto yeah
oh god he's problematic and i knew it so
anyways we have a bunch of mcu prompts
here i'm going to read them and when i
count to three yes when i count to three
let's do a practice because you i love
to jump the game the gun on the count of
three you're gonna raise either your red
or your green flag okay one
two
one
two
three
perfect we know how to play it yeah um
and you guys again in the chat greens
for good to go
uh reds for
gotta say no gotta say gotta say no
ready
when he criticizes your personality and
he has three
when he criticizes your personality but
he's got three three what three what
personalities okay oh
like a moon night yep
one
two
three
okay whitney you're the odd man out
why would you say why'd you say red wait
because if he criticizes your
personality but he has three
personalities i kind of want to hook up
with all that i don't think that it's
cool to criticize anyone's personality
why doesn't he just be sweet why doesn't
moon knight just be tested stephen is
the sweet one so maybe this is more
crazy because uh the chances of a better
personality coming around eventually
maybe one of them is a little
criticizing but maybe i don't be great
listen
it's very simple f mary kill
mark spector's characters
the answer is jake lockley for all three
oh oh okay okay and i'm trying to see
him i've seen a lot of reds a lot of
people ready
yeah be nice i gotta walk personality
talk personality yeah i got a bad person
little pieces of joy
making them yours make
when their team iron man in civil war
when their team iron man in civil war
okay i'm ready for this one you ready
i'm ready for this one i know you're
ready for this i'm ready for this one
one two
three
brandon no yes no iron man was right
brandon no these super humans have got
to be stuck inside we gotta put them
down put them on the raft
you know when you're watching a certain
news network
and you're like i i'm not going to say
which one because then there's going to
be some butt hurt people in the chat
that are like our completely fictitious
news network is is you shouldn't you
shouldn't be political it's not
political one network just only lies
anyway every once in a while they'll
have an anchor on there that i'm like
can i google and see if she ever got in
a bathing suit on instagram because
she's attractive what is the point the
point of this is you may not agree with
what iron man had to say but you got to
admit he looked good saying that oh
okay i think me and when you're on the
right side especially with the chat i
mean i can't i think the fulcrum of this
whole argument
centered around wanda and i think it's
been shown yeah that maybe she should
have been watched a little closer to
wanda in the first place she has her
reasons
she has her reasons and then i'm team uh
i'm the only time i'm team captain
america
tony tony had his theories about wanda
and he had his theories about
quicksilver unfortunately for
quicksilver
there were a few holes i'm just saying
if they would have checked in
[Music]
i hate you
the third topic when they wield dark
mystical powers
but have dark crusty black fingertips
when they wield dark mystical powers but
have dark crusty black fingertips
one
two
three
she's still hot i don't care no it's not
just her it's doctor strange
with those fingers yeah miss me with
those fingers
i'm fine with it
you want a tickle you want to tickle
tommy those hands got to be clean french
manicured yeah french tips french tips
i'm not putting those in my mouth oh
yeah that's what i was just thinking of
when they're like honey you want a
massage i'm gonna get that away from me
you want to fish hook t michael
i wanna put you clean those fingers
you put a
when she's always saving the universe
but never saving time for you
when she's saving the universe
but never saving time for you there's
also a sad face on this one
one
two
three
oh
okay why we say green i live in this
universe you know uh and she's saving it
so she's saving it you know she needs uh
she needs someone by her side to cook
her dinner
i'm here to just make her dinner to do
the laundry she's saving the universe
she don't have time to do that you know
i'm here well it's always about me i'm
sure 100 why'd you two say red
you put me first
please pitch me
universe yeah
for the universe and you put me last no
i just didn't i mean this is what thor
did like natalie portman kind of like
that's gonna kind of be her argument
when they see each other again right
because he kept like
freaking off to asgard and then she
wouldn't see him forever
and i i don't know i think she's a
stronger person because of it i just
think that if you're gonna if you're
gonna go off world just like take your
girlfriend maybe she can help maybe she
can help you put a vial of my blood
around your neck okay you get my name
tattooed over your heart is this a a
fantastic beast thing or you're making a
gun tommy yes i'm getting a lot of red
flags i think it was mixed for this one
i was seeing a lot of rags
she's a lawyer by day but carries you to
bed and makes you baby spoon every night
she's a lawyer by day but carries you to
bed and makes you baby spoon every night
one
two three this shouldn't even be right
if there's a con to you you are insecure
and you need to figure it out because i
will let her carry me she can be i can
be her jet pack
to carry me like a little baby yeah
she's a lawyer that's good [ __ ]
i want to feel like yeah
mary
mary up that's right i'm glad
tall
you guys i could date each and every one
of you except for that person i put red
x's
and oh wait that was the last one
we have one more that we can do if you
want to do it okay i have one okay what
is it
when he's a real bear
from darkest peru
with an affinity for marmalade
green flag green flag green flag green
flag baby patty immediately i'm not
having a guy he's a real bear he's a
real bear yeah this is last question i
said a real bear anatomically correct
bear question no this is like when you
buy a
young chimpanzee because you're like oh
it's so cute it'll be a lot of fun and
then it grows up and rips your jaw off
okay the bear's gonna grow
up and becomes mighty joe young and
everything is fine brandon oh one
gorilla doesn't kill somebody and
suddenly it's okay i'm fine that's
guilty but i'm just saying i've seen the
revenant i'm not trying to mess with the
bear unless it's a sun bear because
they're stupid and cute i i'm always
gonna mess with paddington but mandatory
fun that was really fun and mandatory
you guys want to talk about the breaker
and breakdown oh yeah let's get to the
breaking breakdown okay so we just put
out a video today that is breaking down
the new 411 thunder tv spot and eric has
a fun little theory that uh jane and
gore's power could be linked sometime
okay sometimes somehow is what i meant
to say because it's all it's all coming
from that blue lightning
baby yeah so what do you what do you
guys think do you guys think that their
powers could be
linked up well i think do we have a clip
oh yeah
sorry i forgot to say that i'm dumb
in the shot of jane from the side this
is part of the sequence which she lands
in the chamber with the statues of the
cosmic entities living tribunal the
watcher death eon and infinity now i'm
wondering if the power ups of gore and
if jane might be linked in this movie
from the same source the cosmic entities
that bless jane to stave off her cancer
and give her mjolnir might be the same
beans that bless gore to stave off his
suffering but ultimately equipped him
with this sword however gore out of
anger may have turned on them forcing
them now to seek out jane to help them
which would make this chamber an
actuality say it with me obi-wan and
boromir it's a tomb i just think it
makes story logic sense for jane and
gore to be thematically linked like that
just to make it hard for thor to kill
gore as it may mean killing jane too or
dooming her to a lack of cancer and
taika waititi did say gore scored great
with test audiences who viewed him as
super sympathetic i think this character
is going to be terrifying but also make
us feel really really bad
before we move on okay
have we addressed that in that one shot
of gore he looks just like uncle faster
from adam yeah but he doesn't like he
really does where he's like i love it
first of all it looks like we walked
down and pooping yeah
we walked in on uncle fester i also
don't think it's hard to sympathize with
him because he has a tragic story i
think you if you have a tragic story
it's not hard to agree with like how
you're doing it i mean that's that's
what released me with killmonger i was
like yeah i understand
the only marvel villain i've ever
sympathized with was carnage
um
yeah i got nothing wrong with gore
he's out there killing guns i've never
met a gun i like so uh take him down
take him down dude
yeah there's no the only reason
theoretically that we're against scores
because we like thor right yeah like
some of the guys we've mentioned they're
like some dads
you got to make room for gold
if board had taken out peter quill's dad
and could have saved us a whole
to save them sometimes but i do love
this idea that gore's from voromir and
like that planet was destroyed
the cosmic entities were like here's a
soul stone for your troubles buddies
so sorry my bad i like the idea that
their powers are coming from the same
place because then will you get that
weird like
no not him and it's like yeah him that
guy that's face looks like a butt
but what would be the stipulation of
like one of them losing their powers or
die dying it wouldn't affect the other
yeah i i don't know if it's like tied
together in some weird way i wonder if
you know
if if gore was involved with the soul
stone in some strange way that it's
atomization and being destroyed released
him in a and that's why he's around now
and hasn't been around before because
i'm i just don't know how long he's been
doing this god-killing stick for him
is it just been a week and he's just
really efficient
and he's just really been a bad week a
well eric i think said in his video also
that i thought was interesting like that
uh the tribunal of gods from there that
they could be the ones and that it's
possible that maybe
gore messed with them at some point got
his powers and then now they're like oh
[ __ ] oh sorry oh shoot darn it oh shoot
darn it shoot dang oh shoot dang uh we
need to like get somebody on our side to
now fight the guy who has these powers
so then they give
lady jane thor her power so that she can
fight right
i still don't see why these beings of
omnipotence or whatever they are chose
jane
like why jane
makes more sense in the comics is in the
comics she gets chosen because thor has
become unworthy right he walked away
yeah yeah and so i mean they just pick
her because she was like she was the
last one to touch the hammer
you know what i'm saying
so like the hammer itself called to her
so it's like the reason in the comics is
because comics yeah because that's how
she got her power
mcu i think you it's easy to be like
there's more than one person that can
wield malnear it's just that how many
people get the shot right yeah no one
gets a shot she got a shot i'm sure like
maybe we'll see that darcy lewis is also
able to oh my god that would be
incredible
howard the duck can do it
kentucky is crazy
he's like what's this car i just wanted
to you howard the duck is not worthy oh
he's done some shady things in his life
yeah he's changed people do change how
about uncle scrooge his uncle scrooge
marvel now uh
it is disney and he's good duck is
marvel now i think
we asked in the chat do you think jane
and gore's powers are linked and 58 of
you said no but that's still pretty
close that's pretty close pretty split
on it
i mean we're telling eric and he's never
gonna do a video for you now
it makes sense thematically that they
would be linked obviously for this story
and this idea that if thor is placed
with the choice of like killing gore but
that will also kill jane because their
powers are like that's that's a heavy
choice to make and she has to say you
can do it you have to you have to you
have to you have to do you have to kill
gore
earthlings are immortal and we all die
because there's microplastics and they
gave me cancer
i think she got cancer from the ether
though yeah that's what i think that's
what you're getting with she should
blame thor for this is all thor's this
is what watchman's
2005 watchbook was staying the entire
time with dr manhattan yeah yeah exactly
what he gave uh no it gave her cancer
right but no it was yeah but it turned
out to not be it wasn't it was you guys
as a world we need to come to peace so
we need to find a common enemy a naked
man that is that giant disappearing
slinging everywhere money making dong
good lord
good lord what a theme we've had today
for the show i guess i want to know what
it felt like for that guy to get his
dick spray painted
was it um
the guy from
where from watchmen yeah billy crudup
yeah he's i think it was just digitally
done yeah
even if it was
and he had to get himself ready every
single day it could be like spider it
could be like uh tom holland and
spiderman where he's out there doing the
flips yeah he's got the suit on he's
doing all the work in there like and
we're just going to make it digital
anyway what it's like
let's do a flip
did you know what if poor billy krebs
getting sprayed dicks every day like
where did they just like replace it what
if he walked into makeup and he was like
dick first today
this is like the hbo show where they had
to do the math of how many people could
like oh
yeah yeah silicon valley yeah silicon
valley we should do this on the break
room on friday break room we'll break
down uh whether or not how much time we
have to dip people in blue yeah we're
gonna get to the bottom of this crud up
blue
dip index billy's uh billy club for your
penis oh most definitely uh we've got a
few minutes left uh there's two big from
our shows tonight yeah two uh uh obi-wan
kenobi episode five you've got some
last-minute questions drop them in the
chat we got some super chats we could
talk about yeah early on the show john
attend threw in a super chat uh would
love to see stan lee's who wants to be a
superhero make a return i don't remember
that it was a reality show where it was
like all these challenges
can you be a superhero
you're doing that on the boys right now
right yeah to get it
i like that when is the musical episode
of the break room dropping it will
probably be an extended mandatory fun on
a friday
i don't know
if we can promise a musical episode
it's too risky
uh
joseph getze uh i already called this
one out but i'll say it again drink
swear and make mandatory fun yes uh
connor lauren wagner tommy's my boy
connor
your father uh you all love it y'all are
beautiful people though
sounds like a concession a little rough
there yeah to be fair i don't hate you
guys either yeah thanks for always
making the last hour of my work day the
best you're welcome tada we're happy to
do that uh
reid cole's saying what if the movie is
like rocket man and all the musical
stuff is made up from joker already said
that i i i i requested it to chicago
maybe this young man hasn't seen chicago
but i like reed cole's when he says yeah
yeah i think all the musical stuff will
definitely be in their heads how about
this nicole b with a four-way tie
comment you all have awesome hair oh
nicole
salon quality yeah
i'll write everybody did you read mozart
number one
i
what does t michael think about the
joker sequel yeah what do you think do
you mind i'm not t michael but if i oh
wow yeah but what would you michael
let's text you what's called maybe it's
actually right now let's call him let's
call him uh while we're calling t
michael his number is 9-1-1
nimbus galleon saying i see the flags
wait a second i love this space
someone's flying in oh oh my god
he didn't send a text he sent a bird he
said a tweet
he's unavailable personally
what what are you doing to perseus percy
what's that
perseus
who asked the question
it's already deleted oh i think it was
mo asked the question
perseus says emma why don't you ammo
your [ __ ] own oh wow wow we didn't
break 200 yeah well guess what
i don't play by the rules oh my gosh i
play for keeps that's a good t-michael
impression
because i've been t michaels the whole
time
surprise only non-problematic that's why
tommy was so non-problematic because t
michael was playing tommy the whole time
he's in my trunk where he's been since
yesterday
the joker sequel
has already been approved at t michael
studios oh my god it'll be rated
m a
40. no one under 40 admitted
graphic nudity realistic sex
unrealistic sex oh my god violence
that'll make you want to go home and
crawl back up inside your mama oh my
goodness snapchat just said wow is that
a bird
it's not a bird it's my son
my legal son
i uploaded my dying son perseus's
conscience into this bird
that was kind of you i guess that you're
illegal what was he dying of pissing me
off oh my gosh
uh uh jacques had a super chat maybe you
could answer this too sure and miss
marvel do they know about magic i don't
care nerd oh my gosh
i don't care i think magic poor's on a
map at least right yeah right people
might know about it we talked about it
in moon night yeah they must know about
magic i'll say yes i'll say
jordan holland asking do you think the
mind flayer will actually cross over to
earth in season five
yes you're our stranger things i think
so i think it's guns he opened up so
many gates how are they gonna keep
building
i i have a uh
ignorant question as a as a latent
stranger things watcher we saw the mind
player previously it was never on earth
we were only seeing the projection of it
through will's eyes my player was able
to come to our world because a piece of
it got trapped inside of will when it
possessed well so it was laying dormant
in our world but the mind flare was like
when we see the mind flayer flash
at the very end of season two that was
supposed to be from the perspective of
the of the upside down so that's hopkins
and the upside down okay so yeah so
that's how it gets trapped
yeah so it gets trapped and so then that
one little piece that it gets
reactivated when 11 reopens the gate oh
sorry when the russians reopened the
gate and said yeah
so yeah so that's when it comes back
thank you so much
very helpful stuff someone said the
justification of joker is something we
love to see the gasification we should
justify the joker
i mean i like saying it like that listen
i'm excited for lady gaga ever since i
saw her documentary
ever since i saw her documentary i'm on
her side her hips are killing her you
guys can make her perform at the super
bowl or hipster she's going to yell at
everyone until she gets she's got to
yell at everybody but she still visits
her grandmama we saw the way she treated
eliza so sweet
poor eliza
perseus says he's a little monster
and he was born
oh
paws up little monsters
and finally joel ralston saying big miss
if joker 2 doesn't have bad romance i
mean
you had a great or tommy had a great
tweet before you put him in the trunk
about like uh turning poker face the
joker fast everybody i can't read my no
you can't read my joker face
i have a bad romance girl myself oh okay
okay uh like i said if the joker 2
doesn't have the line i'm looking for
i'm going to leave and that line is the
joker baby all right folks i think
that's the end of the break room for
today we got to turn this break room
into an actual break room people got
snacks to eat thank you so much for
joining us breakers roomies we're so
glad you're here uh and we hope to see
you here tomorrow make sure you watch
your content before you join us tomorrow
because i'm sure we'll be talking
spoilers uh maybe we'll split them up
over two days i don't know it depends on
how much there is to cover could be big
things in both episodes the boys next
episode is a musical and i don't know if
it is next episode but one of the
episodes is a musical orgasm
a musical
my god that's amazing i'm really excited
wow me and tommy will be talking about
it i'm the boys undergrad i swear i am a
co-host of tommy swears is going to be
on the boys underground this week we'll
have to see but join us here tomorrow we
love you have a great rest of your
tuesday goodbye latest getters have a
great time
a long time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you